medical grade clinical professional only
skin care that you can only buy from
skin clinics isn't really a thing I mean
it is a thing like how non-comedogenic
or for oily skin or extra hydrating
products are a thing it isn't a legally
regulated term so any brand can decide
to put medical grade on their products
and only sell them at skin clinics it
isn't like they have high percentages of
ingredients that aren't legally allowed
in drugstore products they're not
allowed to work deeper in the skin there
are some categories of skin care
products that are held to a legally
higher standard but they are in
supermarkets too these are products like
sunscreens and benzoyl peroxide acne
products medical grade doesn't
necessarily mean they have more research
done on them lots of drugstore products
have huge teams of scientists working on
them there are good and bad products
from medical grade Brands there are good
and bad products from drugstore Brands
if your medical grade products worked
really well on your skin have tons of
research behind them have cool
technology and Delivery Systems then
tell us about that you do not need to
make up benefits that don't exist